الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمد محمد رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
استووا استووا
اعتدلوا ساووا الصفوف يت لاذا
جاب الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعم عمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يسبح لله ما في السماوات وما في
الارض الملك القدوس العزيز
الحكيم هو الذي بعث في
الاميين رسولا منهم يتلو عليهم اياته
ويزكيهم ويزكيهم ويعلمهم الكتاب والحكمه
وان كانوا من قبل لفي ضلال
مبين واخرين منهم لما يلحق
بهم وهو العزيز
الحكيم ذلك فضل الله يؤتيه من
يشاء والله ذو الفضل
العظيم مثل الذين
حملوا التوراه ثم لم يحملوها كمثل الحمار
يحملوا
اسفارا بئس مثل القوم الذين كذبوا ايات
الله والله لا يهدي القوم
الفاسقين والله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين قل يا ايها الذين هادوا ان زعمتم
انكم
اولياء لله من دون الناس
فتمنوا الموت ان كنتم
صادقين ولا
يتمنونه ابدا بما قدمت
ايديهم والله عليم
بالظالمين قل ان الموتى الذي تفرون منه
فانه
ملاقيكم ثم تردون الى عالم الغيب والشهاده
فينبئكم بما كنتم تعملون
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحم
ال الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا نودي للصلاه من
يوم الجمعه فاسعوا الى ذكر الله وذروا
البيع ذلكم خير لكم ان كنتم
تعلمون فاذا قضيت الصلاه
فانتشروا في الارض وابتغوا من فضل
الله واذكروا الله كثيرا لعلكم
تفلحون واذا راوا تجاره او لهوا انفضوا
اليها وتركوك
قائما قل ما عند الله خير من اللهو ومن
التجاره والله خير الرازقين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اللهه شا
الله
الحد ض
[Silence]
ان
الله 830 845
[Silence]
12ح
الله 15
20 all 345
[Silence]
‏as30 that in mind and be
prep some
mn انء الله
[Silence]
830 church paring lot beit just the
wills gu lot so follow here more likely
ex
[Silence]
‏flow chose
and as are
cor done serv ‏we have a light breakfast
it's a left
turn no right turn
all so you can't go towards lara has to
goya there will be bouncy houses for
the kids and in some you know adult boys
and girls in we also looking for volun
from both boys and girls and youth club
in to help us out streamline people
into the mus just a reminder for my
sisters specially
‏gy upstairs res primarily for sisters
only if you have a child any age with
you not be all be
upstairs the gym be
openen set broadcast there we will have
a separate m from here can transmit
there but if you have a kid you will not
be all upstairs in the gallery please
keep that in mind so cooperate with us
let make this a beautiful and joyous
time
ان شاء الله جزاك الله خير
[Silence]
‏h
ا
[Silence]
استهوا صلاه التراويح حسبكم الله استوو
استووا الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اذا جاءك
المنافقون قالوا نشهد انك لرسول الله
والله يعلم انك
لرسوله والله يشهد ان المنافقين
لكاذبون اتخذوا ايمانهم جنه فصدوا عن سبيل
الله انهم ساء ما كانوا يعملون
ذلك بانهم امنوا ثم كفروا فطبع على قلوبهم
فهم لا فهم لا
يفقهون واذا رايتهم تعجبك اجسامهم وان
يقولوا تسمع
لقولهم
كانهم خشب
مسنده يحسبون كل صيحه عليهم هم العدو
فاحذرهم قاتلهم الله انا
يؤفكون واذا قيل لهم تعالوا يستغفر لكم
رسول الله لووا رؤوسهم لووا رؤوسهم
ورايتهم يصدون وهم
مستكبرون سواء عليهم استغفرت لهم ام لم
تستغفر لهم لن يغفر الله لهم ان الله لا
يهدي القوم
الفاسقين هم الذين يقولون لا تنفقوا على
من عند رسول الله حتى
ينفضوا ولله
خزائن السماوات والارض ولكن المنافقين لا
يفقهون هم يقولون لئ رج عنا الى المدينه
ليخرجن الاعز منها
الاذل ولله العزه ولرسوله وللمؤمنين
ولكن المنافقين لا
يعلمون يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تلهكم
اموالكم ولا اولادكم عن ذكر
الله ومن يفعل ذلك ف ائك هم
الخاسرون وانفقوا مما رزقناكم من قبل ان
ياتي احدكم الموت
فيقول فيقول رب لولا اخرتني الى اجل قريب
فاصدق واكن من
الصالحين ولن يؤخر الله نفسا اذا جا ا
اجلها والله خبير بما
تعملون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يسبح لله ما في السماوات وما في
الارض له الملك وله الحمد وهو على كل شيء
قدير هو الذي خلق م فمنكم كافر ومنكم مؤمن
والله بما تعملون
بصير خلق السماوات والارض بالحق وصوركم
فاحسن صوركم واليه
المصير يعلم ما في السماوات والارض ويعلم
ما تسرون وما
تعلنون والله عليم بذات
صدور الم ياتكم نبا الذين كفروا من قبل
فذاقوا وبال امرهم ولهم عذاب
اليم ذلك بانه كانت تاتيهم رسلهم بالبينات
فقالوا ابشر
يهدوننا فقالوا
ابشر يهدوننا فكفروا وتولوا استغنى
الله والله غني
حميد زعم الذين كفروا ان لن يبعثوا قل بلى
قل بلى وربي
لتبعثن ثم
لتنبؤن بما عملتم وذلك على الله
يسير فامنوا بالله ورسوله والنور الذي ان
انزلنا والله بما تعملون
خبير يوم يجمعكم ليوم الجمع ذلك يوم
التغابن ومن يؤمن بالله ويعمل
صالحا يكفر عنه سيئاته ويدخله
جنات ويدخله
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
ابدا ذلك الفوز
العظيم والذين كفروا وكذبوا باياتنا اولئك
اصحاب النار خالدين فيها وبئس
المصير ما اصاب من مصيبه الا باذن
الله ومن يؤمن بالله يهد قلبه والله بكل
شيء
عليم واطيعوا الله واطيعوا
الرسول فان توليتم
فانما على رسولنا البلاغ
المبين الله لا اله الا هو الله لا اله
الا هو وعلى الله
فليتوكل المؤمنون
الله لا اله الا هو وعلى الله فليتوكل
المؤمنون يا ايها الذين امنوا ان من
ازواجكم واولادكم عدوا لكم
فاحذروهم وان تعفوا وتصفحوا وتغفروا فان
الله غفور
رحيم انما اموالكم واولادكم فتنه والله
عنده اجر
عظيم فاتقوا الله ما استطعتم واسمعوا
واطيعوا
وانفقوا خيرا
لانفسكم ومن يوق شح نفسه فاولئك هم
المفلحون ان تقرض الله قرضا حسنا يضاعفه
لكم ويغفر لكم والله شكور
حليم عالم الغيب والشهاده العزيز
الحكيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرح
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يا ايها النبي اذا
طلقتم
النساء فطلقوهن
لعدتهن واحصوا
العده واتقوا الله ربكم لا تخرجوهن من
بيوته هن ولا يخرجن الا ان ياتين بفاحشه
مبينه وتلك حدود
الله ومن يتعد حدود الله فقد ظلم نفسه لا
تدري لعل الله يحدث بعد ذلك
امرا فاذا بلغن اجلهن فامسكوهن
بمعروف او
فارقوهن بمعروف
واشهدوا ذوي عدل منكم واقيموا الشهاده
لله ذلكم يوعظ به من كان يؤمن بالله
واليوم الاخر ومن يتق الله يجعل له مخرجا
ويرزقه من حيث لا يحتسب ومن يتوكل على
الله فهو حسبه ان ان الله بالغ امره قد
جعل الله لكل شيء
قدرا ولا ان يئسن من المحيض من
نسائكم ان ارتبتم
فعدتهن ثلاثه اشهر
واللائي لم
يحض واللاه الاحمال
اجلهن ان يضعن
حملهن ومن يتق الله يجعل له من امره
يسرا ذلك امر الله
انزله اليكم ومن يتق الله يكفر عنه سيئاته
ويعظم له
اجرا اسكنوهن من حيث سكنتم من وجدكم ولا
تضاروهن
لتضيقوا عل
وان كن اولات حمل فانفقوا عليهن حتى يضعن
حملهن فان ارضعن لكم
فاتوهن اجورهن واتمروا بينكم
بمعروف وان تعاسرتم فسترضع له
اخرى لينفق ذو سعه من سعه
ومن قدر عليه رزقه فلينفق مما اتاه
الله لا يكلف الله نفسا الا ما
اتاها سيجعل الله بعد عسر
يسرا
وكاي من قريه عتت عن امر ربها ورسله
فحاسبناها
حسابا شديدا
حسابا
شديدا وعذبها عذابا
نكرا فذاقت وبال امرها وكان عاقبه امرها
خسرا اعد الله لهم عذابا
شديدا فاتقوا الله يا اولي الالباب الذين
امنوا قد
انزل الله اليكم ذكرا
رسولا من الله يتلوا عليكم ايات الله
مبينات ليخرج الذين
امنوا
رسولا يتلو عليكم ايات الله مبينات ليخرج
الذين
امنوا ليخرج الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
من الظلمات الى
النور ومن
يؤمن بالله ويعمل صالحا يدخله
جنات يدخله جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار
خالدين فيها ابدا قد احسن الله له
رزقا الله الذي خلق سبع
سماوات ومن الارض
مثلهن يتنزل الامر هن لتعلموا ان الله على
كل شيء
قدير وان الله قد احاط بكل شيء
علما الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
ستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا ايها
النبي لم تحرم ما احل الله لك تبتغي مرضاه
ازواجك والله غفور
رحيم قد فرض الله لكم تحله ايمانكم والله
مولاكم وهو العليم
الحكيم واذ اسر النبي الى بعض ازواجه حديث
فلما نبات به واظهره الله عليه عرف بعضه
واعرض عن بعض فلما نباها به قالت من
انباك هذا قال نباني العليم
الخبير ان تتوبا الى الله فقد صغت
قلوبكما وان تظاهرا عليه فان الله هو
مولاه فان الله هو مولاه وجبريل وصالح
المؤمنين
والملائكه بعد ذلك
ظهير عسى ربه ان طلقكن ان يبدله ازواجا
خيرا
منكن
مسلمات مسلمات
مؤمنات قانتات
تائبات عابدات
سائحات ثيبات
وابكارا يا ايها الذين امنوا قوا انفسكم
واهليكم نارا وقودها الناس
والحجاره عليها
ملائكه غلاظ شداد لا يعصون الله ما امرهم
لا يعصون الله ما امرهم ويفعلون ما
يؤمرون يا ايها الذين كفروا لا تعتذروا
اليوم انما تجزون ما كنتم
تعملون يا ايها الذين امنوا توبوا الى
الله توبه
نصوحا عسى ربكم ان يكفر عنكم سيئاتكم
ويدخلكم جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار يوم لا يخزي الله النبي والذين
امنوا معه نورهم يسعى بين ايديهم
وبايمانهم
يقولون يقولون ربنا اتمم لنا نورنا واغفر
لنا انك على كل شيء
قدير يا ايها النبي جاهد الكفار
والمنافقين واغلظ عليهم وماواهم جهنم وبئس
المصير ضرب الله مثلا للذين كفروا امراه
نوح وامراه
لوط كانتا تحت عبدين من عبادنا صالحين
فخانتاهما فلم يغنيا عنهما من الله
شيئا وقيل ادخل النار مع
الداخلين وضرب الله مثلا للذين امنوا
امراه
فرعون اذ قالت رب ابن لي
عندك بيتا في
الجنه ونجني من فرعون وعمله ونجني من
القوم
الظالمين ومريم ابنه عمران التي احصنت
فرجها فنفخنا فيه من
روحنا وصدقت بكلمات ربها وكتبه وكانت من
القانتين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله وصحبه ومنوه ومن تبيع باحسان ال
يوم الدين اما بعد
‏and me to announce that sisters in the
backing can step outs so the rest
he my the is nobody lens to me any
so make differ one of you can tell other
people the
toing only is s
‏outs per c so just re kind re guys
[Silence]
ربنا هبلنا من ازواجنا وذريتنا قره اعين
وجعلنا للمتقين امامه
‏very short very
simple digress
[Silence]
‏days عليه
واللام
ex
as ent
[Silence]
عليه
سب ادع ربكم وانم
مقون دعا
‏hands for
man for
me describing what really goes through
our
heads or we raise our hand we ask for
something right i don't know happen
what make
‏remember joke myes taking a
anding with he say ne in
the spit
sid me he makes a joke me not saying
take
ps take he makes makes a joke about ta
ازح رسول الله
صلس
عليه
ح الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏right there three things that happen
make three things
happ first thing you asked for a shiny
car
andy ask for something ex ask
[Silence]
‏even
‏there
[Silence]
ع الله سبهالى
الله
[Silence]
‏my
my
can't
cycle we
is takes
‏takes it is up and stock maret one is
one is up one is down one is up
every
so never endings in nothing
be سحان الله الله
سال meing
point
innn of the
entire the jn size beze of
‏know
[Silence]
سبحان
الله
حرحم الرح الع what
me what it tr means what is is and rah
com from the wom right the r of the
mother that's where the root word comes
out of
from regardless three things i explain
to you right this what happ but do not
stand at night making and being i don't
know i don't know yes no i don't
know adic of dua
اللهبه
وانهى عل لا اله الا انت سبحانك ان منين
[Silence]
‏from e
‏do
[Silence]
‏out الله سبحانه
وتالى خط ذكريا ا ربه نداء خفيه
[Silence]
‏tak
انت الغني ونحن
فقراء علي ولا تجعل منت
[Silence]
ليله
القدر
شباب اللف
العف ربنا حبلنا من ازواجنا وذريتنا قره
اع وجعل وجعلنا للمتقين
اماما دح
[Silence]
رب ربنا جعلنا ازواجنا وذرياتنا قره اع
الله spes and pr sparing tle of ey look
at you happ heart ised you look
at i got
[Silence]
‏seen you you at said
before shouldn't say that you shouldn't
say
that you don't know the time
[Silence]
ربنا حب لنا من ازواجنا وذريه قره
وعلنا لقين امه
there
tak لقين
امامه
سبحان يعني
‏make
among
fathers
make our thefor of
our our
‏manale
mayb
me comm used as
spender in just make clear does not
define gender definition ofender
so my recom
[Silence]
حبه
نابنا من ازواجنا
وذريتنا قره اعن وجعلنا للمتقين اماما
اللهم امين ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وك عذاب النار وكنا عذاب
القبر وكنا عذاب جهنم وكنا ش شر فتنه محيا
الممات وكنا شر فتنه مسيح الدجال ربنا
تقبل منا انك انت السميع العليم وتوب
علينا يا مولانا انت التواب الرحيم وصلى
الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
برحمتك ارحم الراحمين اللهم امين اللهم
امين اللهم امين
استقيموا اعتدلوا استو سووا الصف سدوا
الخلل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين تبارك الذي بيده الملك وهو على كل
شيء قدير الذي خلق الموت والحياه ليبلوكم
ايكم احسن عملا وهو العزيز الغفور الذي
خلق سبع
سماوات طباقا ما ترى في خلق الرحمن من
تفاوت فارجع البصر هل ترى من فطور ثم ارجع
البصر مرتين ينقلب اليك البصر خاسئا وهو
حسير ولقد زينا
السماء الدنيا
بمصابيح وجعلناها رجوما للشياطين
واعتدنا لهم عذاب السعير وللذين كفروا
بربهم عذاب جهنم وبئس المصير اذا القوا
فيها سمعوا لها
زفيرا اذا القوا فيها سمعوا لها
شهيقا وهي تفور تكاد تميز من الغيظ كلما
القي فيها فوج سالهم
خزنتها سالهم خزنتها الم ياتكم نذير قالوا
بلى قد جاءنا نذير
قالوا بلى قد جاءنا نذير فكذبنا وقلنا ما
نزل الله من شيء ان انتم الا في ضلال كبير
وقالوا لو كنا نسمع او نعقل ما كنا في
اصحاب
السعير فاعترفوا بذنبي
فسحقا لاصحاب
السعير ان الذين يخشون ربهم بالغيب لهم
مغفره لهم مغفره واجر كبير
واسروا قولكم او اجهروا به انه عليم بذات
الصدور الا يعلم من خلق وهو اللطيف الخبير
هو الذي جعل لكم الارض ذلولا فامشوا في
مناكبها فامشوا في مناكبها وكلوا من رزقه
واليه
النشور
اامنتم من في
السماء ان يخسف بكم الارض ان يخسف بكم
الارض فاذا هي تم
ام
امنتم من في
السماء ان يرسل عليكم
حاصبا ان يرسل عليكم حاصبا فسوف ف ان يرسل
عليكم حاصبا فتعلمون كيف نذير
فستعلمون كيف نذير ولقد كذب ذين من قبلهم
فكيف كان نكير اولم يروا الى الطير فوقهم
صافات
ويقبض ما
يمسكهن الا
الرحمن انه بكل شيء بصير امن هذا الذي هو
جند لكم ينصركم من دون
الرحمن ان
الكافرون الا في
غرور
امن هذا الذي يرزقكم ان امسك رزقه بل لجوا
في عتو
ونفور افمن يمشي مكبا على وجهه اهدى امن
يمشي
اهداء من يمشي سويا على صراط
مستقيم قل هو الذي قل هو الذي
خلقكم قل هو الذي
انشاكم وجعل لكم السمع والابصار
والافئده
قليلا ما
تشكرون قل هو الذي ذراكم في الارض اليه
تحشرون ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين قل
انما العلم عند
الله
وانما انا نذير مبين
فلما راوه زلفه سيئت وجوه الذين كف
وقيل هذا الذي
كنتم
تدعون قل وقيل هذا الذي كنتم به
تدعون قل ارايتم ان اهلكني الله ومن معي
او
رحمنا فمن يجير
الكافرين من عذاب اليم
قل هو الرحمن
امنا به وعليه
توكلنا
فستعلمون من هو في ضلال مبين قل ارايتم ان
اصبح
ماؤكم
غورا فمن
ياتيكم
بماء معي
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
بسم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم
الله
نون والقلم وما
يسطرون ما انت نعمه ربك
بمجنون
وان لك لاجرا غير ممنون
وانك لعلى خلق عظيم فستبصر
ويبصرون بايكم
المفتون ان ربك هو اعلم بمن ضل عن سبيله
وهو اعلم بالمهتدين
فلا تطع
المكذبين ودوا لو تدهن
فيدهنون ولا تطع كل حلاف مهين
هماز مش
الشاء بنميم من ناع للخير معتد
اثيم عتل بعد ذلك
زنيم ان كان ذا مال
وبنين اذا تتلى عليه اياتنا قال اساطير
الاولين س سنسمه على
الخرطوم انا بلوناهم كما ب لولا اصحاب
الجنه اذ اقسموا ليصرمنها
مصبحين ولا
يستثنون فطاف عليها
طائف من ربك وهم
نائمون فاصبحت
كالصريم فتنادوا مصبحين ان اغدوا على
حرثكم ان كنتم
صارمين
فانطلقوا وهم يتخافتون
الا
يدخلنها اليوم عليكم مسكين وغدوا على حرد
قادرين فلما راوها قالوا انا
لضالون بل نحن
محرومون قال اوسطهم الم اقل لكم لولا
تسبحون قالوا سبحان ربنا انا كنا
ظالمين فاق قبل بعضهم على بعض
يتلاومون قالوا يا ويلنا انا كنا
طاغين عسى ربنا ان يبدلنا خيرا منها انا
الى ربنا
راغبون كذلك
العذاب ولعذاب الاخره
اكبر لو كانوا
يعلمون ان
للمتقين عند ربهم جنات
النعيم
افنجعل المسلمين كالمجرمين
ما لكم كيف
تحكمون ام لكم كتاب فيه
تدرسون ان لكم في لما
تخيرون ام لكم ايمان علينا بالغه الى يوم
القيامه
ان لكم لما
تحكمون سلهم ايهم بذلك زعيم ام لهم
شركاء فلياتوا
بشركائهم ان كانوا صادقين
يوم يكشف عن ساق ويدعون الى السجود فلا
يستطيعون خاشعه ابصارهم ترهقهم ذله وقد
كانوا يدعون الى السجود وهم
سالمون فذرني ومن يكذب بهذا
الحديث سنستدرجهم
من حيث لا يعلم
واملي لهم ان كيدي متين ام تسالهم اجرا
فهم من مغرم
مثقلون ام عندهم الغيب فهم
يكتبون فاصبر لحكم ربك ولا تكن كصاحب
الحوت اذ نادى وهو مكظوم
لولا ان تداركه تداركه نعمه من ربه لنبذ
بالعراء وهو مذموم فاجتباه ربه فجعله من
الصالحين وان يكادوا الذين كفروا ليزلقونك
بابصارهم لما سمعوا
الذكر ويق يقولون
انه
لمجنون وما هو الا ذكر
للعالمين الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين
الحاقه ما
الحاقه
وما ادراك ما
الحاقه كذبت ثمود وعاد
بالقارعه فاما ثمود فاهلكوا بالطاغيه
واما عاد فاهلكوا بريح صرصر عاتيه سخرها
عليهم سبع ليال وثمانيه ايام
حسوما فترى القوم فيها صرعا كانهم اعجاز
نخل خاويه فهل ترى لهم من باقيه
وجاء فرعون ومن قبله
والمؤتفكات
بالخاطئه فعصوا رسول ربهم فاخذهم اخذه
الرابيه انا لما طغى
الماء حملناكم في
الجاريه لنجعلها لكم تذكره
وتعيها اذن واعيه فاذا نفخ في الصور
واحده وحملت الارض والجبال فدكتا دكه
واحده
فيومئذ وقعت
الواقعه
وانشقت
السماء فهي يومئذ
واهيه والملك على
ارجائها ويحمل عرش ربك فوقهم
يومئذ
ثمانيه
يومئذ تعرضون لا تخفى منكم خافيه فاما من
اوتي كتابه
بيمينه
فيقول فيقول
هاء مقرا
كتابيه اني ظننت اني لاق
حسابيه فهو في عيشه
راضيه في جنه عاليه قطوفها
دانيه كلوا واشربوا
هنيئا بما اسلفتم في الايام
الخاليه
واما من اوتي كتابه بشماله
فيقول فيقول ق يا ليتني لم اوت
كتابيه ولم ادر ما
حسابيه يا ليتها كانت
القاضيه ما اغنى عني ماليه هلك
عني
سلطانيه خذوه
فغلوه ثم الجحيم صلوه
ثم في
سلسله ذرعها سبعون
ذراعا فاسلكوه
انه كان لا يؤمن بالله العظيم ولا يحض على
طعام
المسكين فليس له اليوم هاهنا
حميم ولا طعام الا من
غسلين لا ياكله
الا
الخاطئون فلا اقسم بما تبصرون وما لا
تبصرون
انه لقول رسول كريم وما هو بقول شاعر
قليلا ما
تؤمنون ولا بقول كاهن قليلا ما تذكرون
تنزيل من رب
العالمين ولو تقول علينا بعض الاقاويل
لاخذنا منه باليمين
ثم لقطعنا منه
الوتين فما
منكم من احد عنه
حاجزين وانه
تذكره
للمتقين وانا لنعلم ان منكم
مكذبين
وانه لحسره على
الكافرين
وانه لحق
اليقين فسبح باسم ربك العظيم
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم سال سائل بعذاب واقع
للكافرين ليس له دافع من الله ذي المعارج
تعرج
الملائكه والروح اليه في يوم كان مقداره 5
الف سنه فاصبر صبرا جميلا انهم ير ه بعيدا
ونراه
قريبا يوم تكون السماء كالمهل وتكون
الجبال كالعهد ولا يسال حميم حميما
يبصرونهم يود المجرم لو يفتدي من عذاب
يومئذ
ببنيه
وصاحبته
واخيه وفصيل ه التي
تؤويه ومن في الارض
جميعا
ثم
ينجيه كلا
انها لظا نزاعه
للشوا تدعو من ادبر
وتولى وجمع
فاوعى الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان
الانسان خلق هلوعا اذا مسه الشر جزوعا
واذا مسه الخير منوعا
الا
المصلين الذين هم على صلاتهم
دائمون والذين في اموالهم حق
للسا حق معلوم
للسائل
والمحروم والذين يصدقون بيوم الدين والذين
هم من عذاب ربهم
مشفقون ان عذاب ربهم غير مامون والذين هم
لفروجهم
حافظون الا على ازواجهم او ما ملكت
ايمانهم
فانهم غير
ملومين فمن ابتغى وراء ذلك فاولئك هم
العادون والذين هم لاماناتهم
وعهدهم
راعون والذين هم
بشهاداتهم
قائمون والذين هم على صلاتهم
يحافظون
اولئك في
جنات
مكرمون فما للذين كفروا قبلك مهطعين
عن اليمين وعن الشمال عزين ايطمع كل امر
منهم ان يدخل جنه نعيم كلا انا
خلقناهم مما
يعلمون فلا اقسم برب المشارق
والمغارب انا
لقادرون على ان نبدل خيرا منهم وما نحن
بمسبوقين فذرهم يخوضوا ويلعبوا حتى يلاقوا
يومهم الذي
يوعدون يوم يخرجون من الاجداث
سراعا
كانهم الى نصب يوفضون
خاشعه ابصارهم ترهقهم ذله ذلك اليوم الذي
كانوا
يوعدون بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم انا ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه ان انذر
قومك من قبل ان ياتيهم عذاب اليم قال يا
قوم اني لكم نذير مبين ان اعبدوا الله
واتقوه
واطيعون يغفر لكم من
ذنوبكم
ويؤخركم الى اجل
مسمى ان اجل الله اذا جاء لا يؤخر لو كنتم
تعلمون قال رب اني دعوت قومي ليلا
ونهارا فلم يزدهم
دعائي الا
فرارا واني كلما دعوتهم لتغفر لهم
جعلوا جعلوا اصابعهم في
اذانهم واستغشوا ثيابهم واصروا واستكبروا
استكبارا ثم اني دعوتهم
جهارا ثم اني اعلنت لهم اسررت لهم
اسرارا فقلت استغفروا ربكم انه كان
غفارا يرسل
السماء عليكم
مدرارا
ويمددكم
باموال
وبنين ويجعل لكم
جنات ويجعل لكم
انهارا ما لكم لا ترجون لله
وقارا وقد خلقكم
اطوارا الم تروا ان الله خلق سبع
سماوات
طباقا الم تروا كيف خلق الله سبع
سماوات طباقا واجعل القمر
فيهن نورا وجعل الشمس
سراجا والله
انبتكم من الارض
نباتا ثم يعيدكم
فيها
ثم يعيدكم فيها
ويخرجكم
اخراجا والله جعل لكم الارض
بساطا لتسلكوا منها سبلا فجاج
قال نوح رب
انهم
عصوني انهم عصوني واتبعوا من لم يزده ماله
وولده الا
خسارا ومكروا مكرا
كبارا وقالوا لا تذرن
الهتكم ولا تذرن ودا ولا سواعا ولا يغوث
ويعوق
ونسرا وقد اضلوا كثيرا فلا تزد الظالمين
الا
ضلالا ولا تزد
الظالمين الا
ضلالا
مما
خطيئاتهم اغرقوا فادخلوا نارا فلم يجدوا
لهم من من دون الله
انصارا وقال نوح رب لا تذر على الارض من
الكافرين
ديارا
انك ان تذرهم يضلوا
عبادك ولا يلدوا الا كافا جرا
كفارا رب اغفر لي ولوالدي
لمن دخل بيتي
مؤمنا ولمن دخل بيتي
مؤمنا
وللمؤمنين والمؤمنات
ولا تزد
الظالمين الا
تبارا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
شف st pleas f the first line all the gs
there space ch can move chair together
don't anything
open don't
[Silence]
‏st
الخل in الله سبحان mer امين الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
ضالين امين
بسم
الله سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر
فهدى والذي اخرج
المرعى
فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا ت
الا ما
شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما
يغفى ونيسرك
لليسر فذكر ان نفعت
الذكر
سيذكر من
يغشى ويتن
نبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى
النار
الكبر ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم
ربه
فصلى بل تؤ ثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله اكبر
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعم عمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم
الله اذا
جاء نصر الله
والفتح ورايت
الناس يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك
واستغفره
انه كان توابا
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر اللهم اجعل
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
السلام اللهم صل
على
اللهم نا ا
[Silence]
الله
اكب السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏st please f the lines
again just the lines as you need
it
st s l
ان شاء
اللهج ان شاء الله شا
الله الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله
قل هو الله
احد الله
الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم انت الحق ووعدك الحق ولقاؤك
الحق وجنه الحق ونار الحق وساعه الحق ونبي
حق ونبينا محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم حق
اللهم بك امنا وعليك توكلنا وبك خاصمنا
فاغفر لنا ما قدمنا وما اخرنا فانت المقدم
وان الموخر وانت على كل شيء
قدير اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن
عافيت وتولنا في منن
توليت وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت وكنا واصرف
عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت انك تقضي ولا يقضى
عليك انه لا يزل من واليت ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وان لم تغفر
لنا
وترحمنا
لنكونن من
الخاسرين اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف
عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا
اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو
فعفونا اللهم في هذه الليله
مباركه لا تدع لنا ذنبا الا غفرت ولا هما
الا
فرجت ولا كربا الا
نفست ولا ميتا الا
رحمت ولا ميتا الا
رحمت ولا اولادا الا
اصلحت ولا دينا الا
قضيت ولا يسيرا الا
يسرت ولا حاجه من الحوائج الدنيا هي لك
رضى ولنا قضيتها ويسرت
لنا اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار ورقاب
والدينا
وذريتنا
وازواجنا وارحام
وامهاتنا
وابائنا ومشائخ
واصحابنا وادخلنا جنه مع
الابرار يا عزيز يا
غفار ربنا هب لنا من ازواج نا قره اعين
وجعلنا
للمتقين
اماما ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا
وذريتنا قره اعين واجعلنا
للمتقين
اماما يا حي يا
قيوم يا حي يا
قيوم يا حي يا قيوم
برحمتك نستغيث اصلح لنا شاننا كللا ولا
تكل الى انفسنا طرفه
عين اللهم يا سامع الصوت ويا سابق الفوت
ويا كاس عن عظام لحما بعد الموت اغفر
لجميع الموتى
المسلمين الذي شهدك
بالوحدانيه والنبي
بالرساله وماتوا على ذلك اللهم اغفر لهم
وارحمهم وعافهم واعف عنهم واكرم نزلهم
ووسع
مدخلهم واغسلهم
بالماء الثلج والبرد ونقم من الذنوب
والخطايا كما ينقى الثوب ابيد من
الدنس ومتعنا اللهم
باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما احييتنا واجعلهما الوارث
منا واجعل ثرنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على
من عادانا ولا تسلط علينا بذنوبنا من لا
يخافك فينا ولا يرحمنا
اللهم نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به نفسك
او انزلته في كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك
او استاثرت في علم غيب عندك ان تجعل قران
ربيع
قلوبنا وجل احزاننا وذهاب همومنا
وغمومنا اللهم اللهم علمنا منهما جهلنا
وارزقنا تلاوته اناء الليل واطراف النهار
على الوجه الذي يرضيك عن
النار اللهم اسالك كما سالك عبدك ونبيك
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم اللهم اسالك
الجنه اللهم اسالك
الجنه اللهم اسالك الجنه ونعوذ بك من
النار ونعوذ بك من النار
ونعوذ بك من
النار لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا كنا من
الظالمين ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا يا مولانا انك انت
التواب
الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله